[Music]
whoo look what you made her do Taylor
Swift looking all edgy on the cover of
British Vogue her album reputation -
spent three weeks at number one and her
feud with Kim Mae has been reignited
after Kim posted this picture on
Instagram so how state dealing with all
the drama and all the success sit back
and take notes on the things we've
learned since we first met Taylor are
you ready for
the album came out last week and it's
just it's so exciting for me because I
got to write every song on that album
and it was good I'm seventeen of course
I miss my friends but I don't have like
a husband and kids at home this is my
first Grammys I've ever been to and I'm
already so overwhelmed there are so many
famous people here how do you handle it
how do you just contain yourself when we
first met Taylor Swift in 2006 she was
just at the beginning of her giant rise
to startup plan to 20,000 people at
night kind of awesome sometimes you take
like four hours to write a song but this
song I wrote in 15 minutes
[Music]
we kept meeting on red carpets at
different award shows and we noticed one
thing right away the Pennsylvania native
who started writing her own songs at the
age of 12 and became the world's
top-earning celeb of 2016 is wicked
smart
was that on audio interference want me
to repeat because I was rambling too and
I'd rather get a clean one I had looked
in the camera sorry I always do that yep
hey knew exactly where to look what to
say and most important she always knew
her passion was music I feel like I
didn't miss out on a childhood I got to
go to school I got to go to my first two
years of high school and experience all
that
and then I got to go on the road and
play shows every night and do what I've
always dreamed of doing and I just
graduated high school I just got my
diploma in the mail which was really fun
[Music]
make no mistake tailors success didn't
happen by accident her sixth album
reputation sold more than 1 million
copies in just four days I have a really
great team of people who don't mind that
I'm really a control freak
I love a challenge and I think that
right now the challenge is figuring out
the next challenge and there's always
something
[Music]
today she's got more than 70 million
Facebook followers but 2007 was actually
the start of Taylor's social media
takeover before she joined to Instagram
and Twitter she was working her own
MySpace page from my myspace I treat it
like it's my personal myspace I don't
treat it like it's been like promotional
tool to promote my music you know it's
like I really like to put stuff about
Who I am as a person because that's what
myspace I thought was supposed to be
let's call 2008 before they were
frenemies yeah Taylor was singing along
to Katy Perry songs on her iPod she even
said this I love her 2009 Taylor was the
Girl Interrupted I'm really happy for
you imma let you finish but Beyonce had
one of the best videos of all time
yeah thanks Kanye but she rose above
wrote new music and built her girl squad
the original member one of my best
friends Emma Stone so if I could ever
active anything with Emma that would be
a dream come true I try to keep my close
friends in my life all the time just I
think it keeps you who you are having
Selina there and just kind of turning it
into a dance party that's always really
fun when award shows turn into more of
like a girls night situation consoling
I'm a nightmare dressed like a daydream
like Taylor and boys yeah we know this
is what you came for you might think I'd
bring up Joe that guy who broke up with
me on the phone
I'm not gonna mention him in my
monologue and if you're wondering if I
might be dating the werewolf from
Twilight from SNL - basically every song
on her albums we hold the list of her
inspirations Joe Jonas was the first in
2008 followed by Taylor Lautner
[Music]
then came John Mayer Jake Gyllenhaal
King Connor Kennedy Harry Styles
[Applause]
Calvin Harris then the other half of
it'll Swift Tom Hiddleston but tase
current guy is British after Joe Alec
you were eventually in relationship
you're gonna run out of things to talk
about so if you two can laugh about
everything like best friends then you're
set I write songs I write on my own
songs and so I'm inspired most of my
boys honestly but I don't date much so
I'm not really getting hard broken alive
they never go into this and be like I
really want to ask you how could you not
write songs about us they say that when
we're breaking up I better not write
song about this and I'm like oh I won't
and then I do I'm not gonna walk home
with any men tonight I'm gonna go hang
out with my friends and then I go home
to the cats no men allowed then get me
in trouble
[Music]